hey this is presh tullwalker in Miss Q's
class one third of the students brought
a teddy bear to school each boy took 12
books each girl took 17 books and each
teddy bear took nine books a total of
305 books were taken out how many girls
were there in Miss Q's class
this is adapted from the UK Junior
mathematical challenge in 2009.
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so we have a word problem we have boys
we have girls we have teddy bears and we
have books
let the number of boys be equal to B let
the number of girls be equal to G now
there are a total of 305 books so we
know this is equal to 305.
one third of the students brought a
teddy bear to school
the total number of students will be B
plus G and then one third of that will
be one-third of B plus G so that's the
number of teddy bears
each boy took 12 books
so the number of books that each boy
took will be equal to 12b
each girl took 17 books so that will be
17 G and each teddy bear took nine books
so it'll be nine multiplied by one-third
of B plus G and that simplifies to be 3
multiplied by B plus G
then we know the total of the books will
be the sum of these three variables and
that will be equal to 305.
so let's just focus on this equation
we can distribute the 3 then we will
group like terms divide both sides of
the equation by 5.
now we will solve for G so that g is
equal to 1 over 4 multiplied by 61 minus
3B
so where do we go from here we know the
total number of boys and girls needs to
be a whole number greater than or equal
to zero
so let's try putting in values for B and
seeing if it's an integer value for G
so B is equal to zero we can calculate
the value of 1 4 of 61 minus 3B we'll
continue doing this for one for two for
three finally we get an integer value 3
and 13. we can continue calculating and
we'll see the next value will be 7 and
that will be equal to 10.
so we have two values B is three and
seven which lead to G is equal to 13 and
10.
so we need to go up by four so the next
one will be 11 and that will be equal to
seven then we have B is equal to 15
which leads to G is equal to four and
then we have B is equal to nineteen and
G is equal to one and that'll be it so
now again we're kind of stuck we have a
table of B and G but it seems like there
could be many solutions so can we
actually go any further well the thing
to remember is the number of teddy bears
so this is equal to one-third the total
number of students and this also needs
to be an integer value greater than or
equal to zero so we can calculate
one-third of B plus G we'll see if
that's an integer value
so in this table we'll see there's only
one value 18 over 3 which is equal to 6.
therefore the total number of boys is
equal to 11 and the total number of
girls is equal to seven and that's the
answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next time
on mind your decisions where we solve
The World's problems one video at a time